à 400 km au-dessus de la terre
américains russes et européens
poursuivent leur collaboration dans leur
station spatiale mais les ordres venus
de moscou ont déjà un impact
question que les cosmonautes russes
mènent les expériences prévu avec sept
astronautes allemand ce qui surprend
c'est que jusqu'à présent le spatial
était au dessus si on peut dire des
contingences terrestres et que même
pendant la guerre froide il y avait un
vrai qu'aux opérations entre russes rss
à l'époque et les américains les
européens là pour la première fois on a
vraiment une décision d'arrêter quelque
chose pire encore la russie est allé
jusqu'à menacer de détruire la station
spatiale c'est elle qui est chargée de
rectifier l'altitude de liesse sans
usage de ses moteurs russes elle
pourrait retomber en morceaux sur la
terre un scénario improbable selon les
spécialistes
les russes n'ont pas d'autres stations
spatiales ils n'ont pas les moyens
d'avoir une station spatiale est
aujourd'hui si les abandonner leur
présence à bord de la station spatiale
internationale et defacto l'année ce
prêt alors il nourrit plus d'accès
habiter un espace plus de destinations
pour l'espace c'est quelque chose qui en
russie est inenvisageable
mais face aux sanctions économiques
européennes des ripostes russes sont
elles beaucoup plus concrète la fusée
soyouz ne lancera plus de satellites
depuis coraux la dernière centaine
d'ingénieurs et techniciens russes a
déjà quitté réduire pertes commerciales
mais aussi perte scientifique ce petit
robot européen censé décoller pour mars
grâce à une fusée russe risque de rester
longtemps cloué au sol tous les
programmes spatiaux sont ainsi menacés
il y aura certainement des changements
majeurs à l'avenir il est encore trop
tôt pour savoir à quoi ils ressembleront
vous devez vous rappeler que nous
dépendons les uns des autres
en cessant de vendre ses technologies
spatiales aux occidentaux la russie
devra aussi se passer d'importantes
rentrées d'argent